he was a third round pick in the 1999
major league draft and after 11 seasons
in minnesota he ranks third in home run
sixth in runs batted in ethan hits and
walks in twins history he hit 30 or more
home runs three times
he was named to four straight all-star
teams as a twin won two silver slugger
awards and was the 2006
american league most valuable player
we have 33 members in the twins hall of
fame only fitting
the number 33 gets inducted today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
given the opportunity
i would do it all again
the start the first
the peak and the end
the injuries
the derbies the playoff failures
the whole thing
i've lived a life that people
including myself have dreamt about
and it was all worth it
thank you
[Applause]
right here john
gantt
he's making his 20th start of the season
he's five and nine
you're right three seven six sinker
cutter change up fastball two strikes to
the chat
and gam pitches around the lead off walk
a scoreless top of the first for the
blue jays
robbie ray making his 31st start of the
season and none have been bigger than
this one in my mind and robbie ray has
had a couple of good ones and a couple
not so good in the month of september
but even in his two bad outings against
baltimore and tampa bay he only allowed
three runs he didn't get out of the
fifth in both of those starts but
tonight he's pitching after a loss and
this season he's five and two after a
blue jays loss and boy do they need a
win
softly hit and over the reach of bishop
cross polanco a bat
good exchange
for jorge he gets the first base hit
that's kind of where the jays are right
now there's inside to donaldson and the
base hits followed by a walk there are
two aboard now for garber
lead runner goes and there's no throw
polanco steals third base
now one outrunners on the corners
and the 3-2 is sent to deep center field
racing to back springer oh what a catch
springer with a fantastic catch
in deep center field the twins will get
a run out of it but what a play by
george springer 411 feet away and he has
a little bit extra extension just before
he slams into the wall and that's why
you want george springer on the field
playing center field for you oscar
hernandez will lead it off
and now he swings and he lifts one to
left center field and this one is easily
out of the ballpark
[Applause]
what a shot from oscar hernandez to tie
the game
watch this location that's a spinner and
a cutter that just stays right out over
the plate and this thing is high and
deep
nice job by dickerson to draw the walk
here's randall grichik
and this one is lined to right field and
it's down for a base hit
and kicked around a little bit by rooker
and now espinal is going to get the wave
and coming to score
out at third is grechik but espinal had
already slid across the plate so the run
will count as the rooker error
gives the blue jays a run
one two and that's a fair ball long
throw by donaldson sails past sano
and springer is on his way to second
base
springer at second base here to begin
the top of the third
and this one is sent to right field and
that is down for a base hit springer's
going to be held at third
first pitch swinging
ground ball to third to second one and
back to first it's a double play
and george springer is still at third
base
so they don't get anything out of that
marcus simeon will lead off the sixth
for the blue chase
and now simeon clubs the ball deep left
field and he has gone deep
number
43
for marcus simeon
that ties the all-time record for the
most home runs ever hit in a season by a
second baseman and it has given the blue
jays a 3-1 lead
[Applause]
donaldson can't make a play it scoots
under him into left field
and around a third on the play comes
beau
that's line to left
gordon dives lays out makes a nice catch
to end the inning
saw young candidate and
he's had a great season so far drilled
to left hit hard
the bullpen off the base of the wall and
donaldson will start the inning with a
[Applause]
double he got him to chase that slider
down and in for a big out
it's been a battle at times he has
walked four tonight but he has allowed
only one run
[Applause]
to left field to dickerson and the
inning is over ray gets out of it
he gets through six and the blue jays
still have their two run lead so now
george springer
to left field
well hit
and how about that george springer
maybe that'll break him out of it a
two-run home run to left where he was
over 16 and then he connects on this
breaking ball just stays on the inside
part of the plate but he goes down and
golfs it into the second deck in left
field
the season like he had last year and
then to build on that with a great year
this year
and he's got himself a base hit his
second hit of the night
he's running
and that is through donaldson and into
left field and around a third on the
play
comes to oscar hernandez another good at
bat for santiago espinal
1-1
and a ground ball base hit through the
right side
and to score is hernandez around to
third is espinal
janssen finds a hole and it is six to
one
the one
bouncer to short backhanded by bo this
should do it his throw finishes the ball
game
and the toronto blue jays pick up a
much-needed victory winning 6-1 in
minneapolis tonight